[Musik]
[Applaus]
und es gibt jedoch die liebe die zwei
menschen zusammenführt weil sie bier
scheint einfach zusammengehören so
geschah es mit manueller egger aus
bayern und christian hilfe aus dem
aargau heute läuten auch für das
gehörlose paar die hochzeitsglocken
[Musik]
im sommer vor einem jahr der christian
um manuelas hand angehalten
seither bereiten sie sich auf ihren
schönsten tag vor und haben sich
inzwischen zivil das jawort gegeben
[Musik]
auch die herzen von uli bärtschi und
andrea buchecker haben sich gefunden
bald wird sie in jedem kleid vor ihm
stehen dass sie im februar ausgesucht
hat und dann werden die ringe für immer
miteinander getauscht
christian reich leben am vor sechs
jahren eine unerwartete wende in der
dominikanischen republik lernte er die
anwender können jetzt sind sie mann und
frau treten petkovic und aldiana
novakovic haben sich einst via internet
kennengelernt
sie trauten sich und feierten eine
glamouröse serbisch-orthodoxe hochzeit
ich habe als vorderen schon viele viele
hochzeiten durchgeführt die arbeiten
haben sich als thema für die hochzeit
ausgesucht
der in der bibel gibt es etwa fünf
geschichten zum thema wer aber in jeder
geschichte ist der bär ein wildes tier
das immer auch menschen frisst
ich fand das nicht so passend für eure
hochzeit
ich habe ein paar sachen der sondern
auch ein mensch kommt bärenstark seien
auch in der ehe gibt es manchmal
schwierige momente manuela du hast du
hast christian kennen gelernt und bist
von deiner familie deine heimat weg zu
ihm gekommen
doch braucht mut und stärke
christian
du hast manuela kennengelernt und für
dich war es klar sie ist die richtige
du bist dir sicher
andrea ist seit einigen tagen nicht mehr
buchecker sondern bärtschi in einer
familiären feier haben sie und oli zivil
geheiratet
heute aber ist der große tag dass sich
uli voit daran zweifelt niemand
nur andrea nicht was ihr bräutigam in
diesem augenblick gerade so tut
rooney verpasst nämlich seinen bruder
daniel erst mal eine angemessene frisur
während er sich auf all das freut was
der tag bringen wird
mit dem lehrer also mit dem
hochzeitsmarsch mit dem originellen
russen spielen
er vertraue ich nach hause filme 15 grad
polier der firma dazu wahrscheinlich als
zweitauto und nachher noch jung war und
den sport
ganz erreicht
in der kleinen kirche in merligen nähert
sich die hochzeitsgesellschaft um diese
zeit den großen augenblick
ich will mit dir zusammen leben
darum wünsche ich für unseren
gemeinsamen lebensweg dass wir unsere
liebe pflegen
das wird oft miteinander lachen
[Musik]
das wird oft lachen dass unser glück
bestand hat ich verspreche dir respekt
ehrlichkeit und lieben
ich verspreche die respekt ehrlichkeit
und liebe ich liebe dich für eben
ich liebe dich für immer
[Musik]
angus wir brauchen besetzt
[Applaus]
[Musik]
in den
kurz vor mittag die sonne steht in ihrem
zenit schreiten manuela und christian
egger aus der kirche heraus und hinein
in ihr neues leben als verheiratetes
paar
[Musik]
zb hat sich selber
die kirchliche trauung von andrea und
uli findet erst am nachmittag statt
andreas familie hat noch ein wenig zeit
um das nesthäkchen ins glück zu
verabschieden
nur noch kurze augenblicke dauert es nun
bis andrea endlich vor ueli stehen wird
nicht etwa vor der kirche sondern auf
dem ruf der berge
[Musik]
er hatte beim spurt
sechs jahre lang hat christian reich
diesen tag herbeigesehnt werden wir nie
da kommt mit dem flug wk 0 35 aus punta
cana landet sie heute in kloten
kaum jemand außer christian hätte das
noch für möglich gehalten
und dann ist sie endlich da
nach knapp neunstündigen flug nidda in
christians 1
[Musik]
die kirchliche trauung von andrea und
uli findet um halb zwei statt
da bliebe eigentlich noch zeit für eine
bratwurst vom grill
[Musik]
bei
so bleibt es bei der kalbsbratwurst
genauso wie es andrea geplant hat und
ich glaube ist da los
man muss ich gucken
[Musik]
in kloten hash nicht nur einkommen
sondern stets auch eingehen aldiana und
treten petkovic fliegen heute in die
flitterwochen
dort vor schlichter woche dreimal pro
woche oder rot rot schlägt berufe
erfahren nachdem ganze altstadt von
tallinn und st
pc mit 16 stimmen
ich bin ein fürst und wie immer wenn ich
muss flüge vom samstag darum hoffe ich
dass ich auch nicht ausschloss
das würde ja
[Musik]
kein paar auf dieser welt das nicht das
glück des schönsten tages festhalten
wollte
[Musik]
von henrik
unweit von ton entfernt erwarten die
gäste das brautpaar doch zum büro gibt
es für manuela und christian noch einen
besonderen hatten eine überraschung von
christians arbeitskollegen von der firma
wieder und die 2 die manuela unserer
christian wir müssen jetzt was machen wo
man das geschenk zukommen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich glaube jetzt kommt die große hilfe
denn die zwei nicht dass hier glaubt
christian muss letztes machen ein
manöver muss es machen will özkan habe
die aufnahme ist manuela zu erklären zu
zeigen wie das geht und dann musst du
das machen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
im betonblock verpackt ist ein gutschein
für zement kies und andere
baumaterialien
diese sind hochwillkommen für die
umgebungsarbeiten die christian und
manuela rund ums eigene zuhause geplant
haben
[Musik]
[Applaus]
herr unser gott wir bitten dich um das
große jahr für alle und andrea
liebe andrea paoli ich lese euch ein
paar stellen aus der bibel vor
wie man auf die elbe ziehen kann denn
liebe uhr je mehr man weiß wie man
verstimmt manchmal bis nicht ganz gut
und gott der herr sprach es ist nicht
gut dass der mensch allein sei ich will
ihm eine gehilfin machen die und ihn sei
ich will ihm eine gehilfin machen
bedeutet nicht dass ja eine dienstmagd
ist ich wünsche euch dass ihr euch in
eure in eurem leben auf gleicher höhe
begegnet und so lebt darum bitte ich
euch nun kommt nach vorne zur frau
handeln
so frage ich dich
juli hier in dieser kirche und vor
versammelter gemeinde willst du deine
frau andrea auch aus gottes hand
annehmen und verspricht so ihr die treue
zu halten in guten wie in bösen tagen in
gesundheit und krankheit und sie zu
lieben zu achten und zu ehren alle tage
bis der tod euch scheidet so antworte ja
wenn die dsl gang risse oder schatz der
betrug meinte die immer du wirst mir
eine frau sich gelehrte vergangen zu
herzen und will keine anderen zugestehen
uni weltruhm als zeit der welt kredite
den ring vor mir andrea nimmst du deine
ehemann uli auch aus gottes hand an und
verspricht so in die treue zu halten
alle tage bis der tod euch scheidet so
antworte ja ja die liebe die liebe die
welt um mehrfach mich wie eine wii
mieten eingenommen kante gibt die so
fest und ruhm darin als teil von ihnen
erlebt so reicht euch die hände
gott herr hat euch als mann und frau
verbunden er ist euch treu er wird zu
euch stehen und das gute das er begonnen
hat auch vollenden
im namen des vaters des sohnes und des
heiligen geistes wird hinten im frieden
[Musik]
im august bei hochsommerlichen
temperaturen fast wie in der
dominikanischen republik tritt wieder an
der seite von christian reich in rüti
erstmals in den ochsen ein
[Musik]
ja
die welt geflogen
[Musik]
als christian mit bieren wieder in den
keller hinunter steigt vor bayern kisten
und flaschen
ist er glücklich und sie macht eine gute
miene dazu
[Musik]
ich werde hier alles aufräumen
nein
[Musik]
der größte tag im leben ist es ganz
bestimmt für andrea und willy betsch
vereinskollegen stehen spalier als die
frischvermählten in gebersheim aus der
kirche treten
[Applaus]
wegen den schlager ist nur heißt sie
aber irgendwie hätte den moment ein
zieht es die ganze zeit noch getroffen
für gewisse qualität habe meine größten
und wegen weltgrößter kinder verletzt
[Musik]
inzwischen sind aldiana und treten
petkovic in paris angekommen
als sie beim hotel einchecken
präsentiert sich die stadt der liebe
kühn & rau ja schatz also erstens sind
habe ich jungfräuliche gehe was mit
michael sting mit sechs für die deg ich
habe mich kurz um möglichst
[Musik]
für die mitglieder schaffen sie haben
noch nach ganz kurzer gang mit dem
flugzeug
die partie hat schon mehrfach bei den
schweizer meisterschaften in hand mit
obenaus geschwungen
andreas jetzt zum ersten mal auf dieser
maschine
wer von den beiden wird an ihrem
schönsten tag diesen ungleichen
wettkampf für sich entscheiden
[Musik]
zwei gleich große flächen gras stehen
bereit und ebenso zwei gleich ehrgeizige
brautleute
[Musik]
juli muss andrea im ersten zweikampf
ihrer noch jungen er den vortritt lassen
[Applaus]
so wirklich so sicher
ich hab zum wechsel rissen ab
man könnte sich die allgemeine lage in
der stadt der liebe auch besser
vorstellen als johannas und tretens
erste reise als ehepaar hat sie nach
paris geführt
auf der sehen wollen sie heute eine
schifffahrt unternehmen
weil
gutes gefühl würden wir bestimmt im
frühling sehen und sie hätte und was
macht man das macht und jetzt sehen wie
wir das jetzt machen wollen
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
ob ich dich nicht los
andreas geschwister haben mit ihrem
geschenk den geschmack des brautpaars
voll getroffen
liebe liebe gäste
wir alle sind heute zusammengekommen um
mit manuela und christian ihren
schönsten tag zu feiern
als ich von der frohen botschaft gehört
habe dass ihr zwei heiraten wollte war
ich sehr glücklich aber auch ein
bisschen traurig weil ich dachte jetzt
verliere ich meine tochter
wie schnell doch die zeit vergeht eben
hielt ich sie noch als kleines baby in
den armen
jetzt ist sie eine wunderschöne kluge
frau die genau weiß was sie will
aber jetzt weiß ich dass die
kein verlust ist sondern es ist ein
gewinn
christian ist der mann der dich liebt
und für dich sorgen wird und deshalb
kann ich mit ruhigem gewissen sagen ich
hab keine tochter verloren nein ich habe
einen sohn gewonnen
meine lieben kinder wie vor ich jetzt
meine rede bnd möchte ich noch
versichern dass wenn ihr auch jetzt
selber eine kleine familie seit wir
immer für euch da sein werden wenn ihr
das wollt und uns braucht und erheben
das glas sowie leider ganz auf eur
herzlichen glückwunsch
[Applaus]
[Musik]
zur gaudi einer jeden gut
schweizerischen hochzeit gehören spiele
und prüfungen bei denen sich das
brautpaar im verlaufe ihres schönsten
tages bewähren muss und weil bei andrea
und oli der kinderwunsch kein geheimnis
ist haben sich die verwandten etwas
entsprechendes einfallen lassen
[Musik]
in der chemie hüter über dem thunersee
steht christian hilfiger vor der
schwierigsten prüfung des tages
liegt
[Musik]
doch schon nach dem zweiten tanzschritt
wird allen anwesenden klar
beflügelt von der liebe und vom glück
kann christian heute gar nichts falsch
machen
[Musik]
ausgeprägt wenn weniger sowie von links
vor der selben situation steht in der
ostschweiz olli banjo vor dem tanz
könnte sich eine prise schnupftabak
[Musik]
da
von herzen die sich gefunden haben war
vor fünf wochen an dieser stelle die
rede von herzen die sich vorerst noch im
dreivierteltakt schlagend neuen aufgaben
stellen werden
andrea und orly wurden in zukunft kinder
haben
doch vorerst sind die kälber die zwei
tage nach der hochzeit zur welt kamen
der einzige nachwuchs auf dem hof
[Musik]
christian reiß zukunft ist die
dominikanische republik
doch zuerst hat ihm seine bieren wir
nieder wie versprochen das gemeinsame
schlafzimmer verschönert
manuela und christian hilfiger ist das
glück förmlich anzusehen er trägt sie
auf händen und sie trägt unter ihrem
herzen ein süßes geheimnis
manuela und christian werden mama und
papa bräuchte es einen beweis dafür dass
sich neckt er sich wirklich liebt hier
ist er mit aldiana und räten petkovic
haben sich die zwei richtigen gefunden
das waren die hochzeits geschichten von
vier paaren die in der schweiz in diesem
jahr geheiratet haben
mit ihnen haben 40.000 weitere paare
diesen schritt gewagt hals über kopf die
einen wohl überlegt die anderen alle
hatten sie ihre ganz persönlichen gründe
dafür
ob aus überzeugung oder gegen
widerstände
am ursprung stand für all dieser
menschen eines der unerschütterliche
glaube an die liebe
[Musik]
ja ich will heiraten in der schweiz mit
glück mikroversicherungen blue beetle
seit 20 jahren für sie da